herr laschet fahren sie nach nürnberg
fahren sie in die heimatstadt von maik
rosner und bieten sie dem
csu-vorsitzenden die kanzlerkandidatur
an die neuesten zahlen heute von forsa
dem meinungsforschungsinstitut sind so
verheerend für die cdu dass dieser weg
der richtige ist ist es kein weg nach
canossa sondern einer im dienst ihrer
partei
23 prozent für olaf scholz und 22
prozent für sie und die cdu das ist
historisch seit 2006 war die cdu nie
mehr hinter der spd
wenn ich das sagen darf haben es
geschafft denken sie jetzt nicht an sich
denken sie an die union denken sie an
ihre cdu denken sie an die kanzlerschaft
denken sie an die führung einer
koalition und denken sie dann eben auch
an markus söder es wäre eine große geste
die ihnen viele ihrer parteimitglieder
und wahrscheinlich auch viele deutsche
banken würden fahren sie nach nürnberg
maik rosner ich bin sicher er wartet
schon
[Gelächter]
ja ich würde es machen wie im fußball
mit emotion alleine die sind zwar da
wenn du plötzlich nach 2006 und vor die
presse krise geht immer weiter runter
aber in sonne frage auch einen monat vor
den wahlen bin ich hinauf für analysen
ganz knallhart das heißt ich muss
analysieren in einem oft parteiebenen
warum wieso weshalb aber da ist nicht
mehr viel zeit kein es muss trotzdem
analysiert werden können jedem oft hast
du denn als manager
ein
spiel vier niederlagen fünf niederlagen
du hast doch den trainer damit du hast
den klang das anders natürlich doch
gerade gesagt da gibt es eine analyse da
gibt es eine spielersitzung danach wird
es fürs naja spiel aufgestellt dann kann
auch mal nationalspieler raus für ihn
war dass auch deine aufgaben hast du
eine hundertprozentig erfüllt und
deswegen haben wir da eine schwachstelle
mehr ändern aber ich bin gegen gefühle
in so einer frage jetzt dass das nicht
so spurlos an einem vorbei geht ist klar
aber nüchtern analysieren und zwar was
er macht die gegenpartei besser wo man
haben wir die fehler war drückte bei uns
müssen wir so ja zu wenn ich was du
sagen die sage ich aus wechselnden
spieler
von tom spieler auswirkt die collage es
verhältnismäßig eindeutig also markus
söder der übrigens er irgendwie auch in
der union ist also irgendwie auch
mitverantwortlich ist für die schlechten
ergebnisse hat aber die weitaus besseren
beliebtheitswerte und die menschen
halten offenbar für den besseren macher
ist das bundesweit ist das so kann sich
ein erstes mal ist es ja sehr schwer
jetzt einfach noch vor der wahl also den
kandidaten auszuwechseln dann müsste
eigentlich ein
parteivorstand erstmal dem parteitag
entscheiden das ist das erste
ein ausweg wäre es wenn laschet selber
zurücktreten würde dann wäre das einfach
hinfahren jammer dass man auch an den
herrn merz zum beispiel denkt nicht nur
an den herrn söder also in den umfragen
werden hatte hatte ja märz auch bei den
jungen leuten erstaunlichen zuspruch
muss ich sagen und ist söder im norden
deutschlands vertretbar ich weiß es
nicht aber ich war also sozusagen er war
ja schon nah dran so der hätte ja
sozusagen zugreifen können wenn er es
gewollt hätte er hat in die fraktion
gehen müssen und dort hätten sie ihn
wahrscheinlich sogar warum hat es nicht
gemacht das ist eine sehr gute frage ich
finde es war falsch und jetzt sage
mir immer noch darüber debattieren zu
nehmen söder ist ein pseudo popstar aber
nicht jeder deutsche möchte so jemand
der immer nur von sich selbst im
mittelpunkt steht als kanzler aber
jeder deutsche muss es auch nicht aber
vielleicht nicht nur 22 prozent der cdu
anhänger sondern 30 oder 32 und die geht
es ja und die glauben alles was wir
wissen eigentlich eher an microsoft also
ich noch nie so verzweifelt fernsehen
gesehen das ist kosten erschüttert ich
musste ich jetzt fast meinen dass durch
dass ich nicht bei mir narben aus der
tasche
diese allem im deutschen die
journalisten jetzt müsst ihr diesen
wahlkampf begleiten bilder von ihr hat
man geradezu aufreizend der
trostlosigkeit aber ich musste sagen
lieber klaus du wirst also auch mit dem
kandidaten nicht glücklich werden denn
markus söder sich gewöhnlich zu seinem
verein club wohl ich ein großer
bewunderer link zum impressum
ich weiß dass du jetzt auf so einen
blender ab vers die in dieser runde das
hätte ich nicht gegangen aber gründe
blender ja ich meine der markus söder
seine kernkompetenz ist er kann sich
verkleiden und er kann als shrek
auftreten kann als der gitarrist von
kiss auftreten könnte sich verkleiden
erhöhte aussehen wie du wenn er sich
eine brille und hinterließ er könnte den
kalli imitieren das ist das
thema dieser brillantes tische aus
spieler in der deutschen politik und ich
finde es wieder mal bezeichnet dass sich
ausgerechnet die hochgeschätzte den
kritischen journalisten wie claus strunz
von blenden lassen ich glaube der
lottomittel laschet noch zu verteidigen
mit diesem desaströsen umfrage
resultaten der ist in seiner ganzen
auch langeweile und unspektakuläre neben
trostlosigkeit ist der authentischer als
söder unerfüllt er führt ein ganz
wichtiges bundesland und er macht das
eben nicht ausblenden
nicht nur die elbe rhein bleiben
anscheinend
einmal muss ich antworten können als
sozusagen der von söder offenkundig
angeblich geplante der an geprägt so ist
es ja nicht meine these ist ja ein
richtig bin jetzt nicht der anführer des
markus hutter völlig gerechtfertig der
anführer des microsoft fanclubs dafür
kenne ich ihn schon zu lang an aber es
gibt und wer hat die besseren chancen
für die union die meisten stimmen zu
holen und da gibt es einfach jetzt sehr
viele daten die gegen armin laschet
sprechen und es gibt sehr viele umfragen
die microsite da deutlich besser sehen
dann würde ich doch wenn ich jetzt zu
sagen der union was zu sagen hätte sagen
jetzt ist der letzte der allerletzten
moment das noch mal neu zu bewerten
stadt genau weiß wie ergebnis
ausgegangen ist unbefriedigend 23 22
wenn ich stehe zu höre denke ich dass
wir 80 zu 20
milliarden das haben wir nach england zu
windig söder in ordnung aber bei 23 22
weil ich eingangs gesagt hat muss
vernünftig analysiert werden wo ist der
bessere wo sind die feder wollbach der
gegner und schwierigkeiten und nicht so
wie du so ein bisschen h ich dachte
jetzt noch ein syrer und ein paar
ja dass er hat es
trotzdem zu hause zu haben
jetzt kommt jetzt muss ich nicht aber
sie
machen und ihr werdet nachdem
sechsundzwanzigster an mich denken die
deutschen sind viel konservativer als
wir glauben bei der umfrage zeigt sich
dass scholz natürlich wahnsinnig
sympathisch sowieso ein
gymnasialdirektor
gefasst und so weiter unter last ist an
mehr so der der karneval typ aber im
endeffekt wenn der deutsche mensch wenn
er frauen diversität in alles was wenn
der in der wahlkabine steht oder seinen
oder seine briefwahl macht wird er ganz
konservativ wählen und deswegen glaube
ich dass er laschet einfach mehr stimmen
bekommen wird die also beziehungsweise
die die union und ich mache mir
überhaupt keine sorgen ich bin ganz
sicher dass der deutsche viel
konservativer ist als die umfragen ist
uns jetzt schauen wir was ich noch
interessant finde bei diesem wahlkampf
wird von außen betrachtet wenn ich mit
deutschen spreche die in der schweiz
sind dann sind die also schon unter
begeistert von dem personal das jetzt
die quasi zu dieser auswahl antreten das
finde ich schon noch bemerkenswert ich
meine deutschland steht an einem ganz
interessanten und wichtigen punkt seiner
entwicklung es geht jetzt die frau
merkel tritt ab ich gehöre ich zu denen
die man da die frau merkel in die tonne
getreten haben ich bin der letzte merkel
verstehe hier und da bist eigentlich
immer vertragen zusammen mit batterie
deshalb mit ihr auch den laschet jetzt
habe ich verstanden jetzt steht den
laschet sozusagen
jetzt aber wieder als andere frisur
beurteilst du die qualität des deutschen
personals im wahlkampf auf einer skala
von 1 bis 6 1 ist das beste denn
durchschnitt was ist das für dich naja
eine 5,5 also wirklich schlecht aber es
geht ja nicht darum jetzt industrie
verringere übungen sind die ästhetik
kritik zu machen es gibt ganz klar hat
darum wenn ich nämlich noch mal in die
unions perspektive versetzte wer holt
die meisten stimmen und da gibt es
begründete zweifel dass armin laschet
die kraft dazu haben wird außer man
glaubt eben an diesen umschwung kurz was
der unterschied zwischen sendern und
laschet ist von seinem typus er ein
teamplayer und zählt er ist quasi die
einzel diva und ich hab' war ein
bisschen hart wurde zu ihm der hat schon
qualitäten der süd aber es tötet jedes
rennen
er ist einfach der selbstdarsteller der
alles allein gemacht werden laschet
scheint mir eher der mann zu sein der
sein team dann zusammen stellt diesen
merkel kurs etwas korrigiert und in
seiner ganzen unspektakulär itt ban dann
wiederum sehr authentisch wirkt aber
natürlich begeistert bin ich nicht ich
wünschte mir dass du endlich mal in die
politik einsteigt cloud oder reihen
doch was los zusammen mit
könnten wir vielleicht machen also ich
glaube wenn wir hier ich habe irgendwie
das gefühl beschlichen wenn wir hier
jetzt abstimmen würden söder oder
laschet ist es eins zu vier man muss man
schnell machen wer sagt söder soll es
machen
ich habe
kurz überzeugt wir sind da
das habe ich mir den larven chorisches
tv total ist minderheit haben sich für
jemanden sein der so einen er ich würde
schon fast sagen you das war gegenüber
seiner eigenen partei er hat doch lasse
so sehr gestiegen sagt ja hinter ihm
gegangen währung ist eigentlich in
gemeinden jeder es geht in der union um
diese fragen jetzt nicht mehr aus meiner
sicht das ist sozusagen kurz vorm
abgrund und ich würde jetzt irgendwie in
khalis welt so es ist sozusagen fünf
spiele verloren der
analyse
abschlag habe ich ja mal die
spielergebnisse sind doch die sachliche
analyse es gibt aber das kleine finale
29 ja aber er kommt doch von 35 verloren
verloren verloren verloren verloren
verloren abgrund oder söder aber ihr
folgt mir nicht gut
drauf steht ist los mit drin das ist
nicht groß leuthen ralf speth da wissen
wir nicht was rauskommt auch leben
darüber denke ich noch mal nach bevor
ich dann nachher in meinem microsoft
bettwäsche ein
stürmer markus söder handlung
ganz klar mir gefällt auch seine hart
wie ja auftritt und es
baut er hat sich auch in der politik
muss man auch diesmal aber das hat
nichts jetzt seine fragen oder ihren
wird so einem wetter lächelt uns alle
noch überraschen der hat nämlich doch
mehr infos als man gemeinhin im ausland
wird er überraschend denn das ist es
[Musik]